You are listening to radiolab radio lash
from w.N y.
S. E. N. N. P. R.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich and today on the podcast.
Hey Robert, can you scoot back a little bit from the mic? Don't worry.
We have a cloak and dagger maritime adventure in secrecy and truth from reporter
Julia Barton. Jeff,
maybe first you could start off just by introducing yourself. Yeah,
so the story for me begins with this guy. Yeah. My name is Jeff Larson.
I'm the data editor at Propublica.
Pro Public has this investigative journalism outfit and Jeff does a lot of their
data based reporting. So in any case,
it was summer of 2013 you know that big story about how the NSA had just been
monitoring billions of Verizon customers that just came out.
Jeff's watching the story like all of us are,
and then the thought occurred to him, Geez,
they're monitoring all of these people. Hey, does that include me?
Mm.
So he goes over to the NSA's website.
He was surprised to find that right there on the site.
You could file a privacy act request for your metadata.
They have a little online form right there,
this service that they offer to everybody.
And so I went ahead and did that and said, this is yourself, you're requesting,
you're saying, what do you,
what do you know about who I called and who I heard from? Yes, exactly.
What were you expecting? A, the best case scenario would be just a, you know,
a page of all of the communications actually to my wife.
My wife's a Verizon customer and I'm in a t and t customer,
so all my phone calls to my wife, I guess I didn't think that I would ever know,
um, any response back so that we hit submit expecting nothing to happen.
Right.
It was actually really, really quick.
I think it was on the order of 10 or 12 days. Um,
you know, it came to my home, uh, addressed sort of a Manila envelope. You know,
my wife called me immediately when she picked up the mail and said, hey,
you know,
you gotta you got a letter from the national security agency and there was
complete panic in her voice.
So now she's looking at the cabinets for small little beeping objects. Yeah,
right, exactly. And when he opened up the letter, cause he read it. Yeah,
I have, I actually have it up right now.
The letter said we cannot acknowledge the existence or nonexistence of such
metadata or call detail records pertaining to the telephone numbers that you
provided.
[inaudible]
exactly. What does one know when one hears that response? I don't know.
I mean, when you're a reporter and you hear that it's sort of the,
it puts you in this weird place.
So Jeff takes the letter into work the next day and he shows it to a colleague
who had been doing a lot of reporting on drone strikes in Guantanamo.
And he's like, what the hell is this? Does it mean something?
And she said that was a Glomar response.
Hmm.
How do you spell, how do you say is? How do you spell Glomar or Glomar?
Glomar is a, g.
L. O. M. A. R. Glomar.
What did you think just of the word I thought it was.
I thought it was a some lawyer named [inaudible] who had a argued associate,
successfully argued the case because it sounded like a bit of legal ease.
I didn't know the fascinating story behind it,
so I started looking into it and right away found this nutty story involving a
nuke, a claw, a billionaire, some manganese,
and this classic tension between secrets being really necessary and really
harmful. Some manganese, but to get there you have to start with this guy. Okay.
Let's just start out by getting your name and how we should identify you. Well,
my name is David Sharp. That's my real name.
This makes it all much more mysterious.
What have been some of your other name during the mission?
My Name was David Scholz,
so in the late sixties David was working at the CIA.
He'd been there for awhile and he got called onto this new thing called project
Azorian. A yes.
I started the program in 1969 here's what you need to know.
[inaudible]
in the late sixties the u s and the USSR were playing this high stakes chess
game with their nuclear submarines cruising around international waters.
There was a lot of harassment that went on inching on each other's territories.
In fact, in January,
1968 a US naval ship was captured after leaving Japan and everyone was worried
that the Soviets had our code books and there was an interest in getting even,
well,
two months later in March of 1968 a Soviet sub called the k one 29 just
vanished. We don't know exactly why it's sunk.
There's all kinds of conspiracy theories about what might have happened.
It just sank to the bottom of the ocean and once the Soviets sent their search
crews out trying to locate it and failed,
we came in and somehow through our sensor technology or whatever reason,
your conspiracy theory of choice might tell you we found the boat.
So then the thought was if we could get inside that thing,
such a bonanza, there was a lot to be learned.
Whether it would be the code books, the cryptographic equipment or,
and this is the big one of the nuclear missiles. It hadn't,
it had nuclear missiles on board. Yep. The chief of naval operations,
he really wanted to see if we couldn't recover that submarine, the whole thing.
The problem was that the sub was three miles below the surface of the ocean and
the pressures at that depth according to David,
are roughly 7,500 pounds per square inch, which meant to get the whole thing up.
They were looking at scenarios where they'd have to live something like 14
million pounds. That's all. No Big One.
So their solution is to get a room full of top secret engineers together and
just start spitballing ideas.
Like what if we just went down there and attach rockets to it and
last the target up to the surface. Uh, we'll wait.
How do we catch it when it comes back down? Cause heavy. What if we, okay,
we could, we could put these um,
pawn tunes or gas filled bags and float the target up except that we can't get
the gas in there because of the pressure.
Boy, these must have been amazing meetings where you could say anything.
You could say that.
So in the end they settled on a claw,
a claw. The idea was to build this Gargantuan eight fingered claw and,
and a boat. And then you would put the claw in the boat,
bring it out on the high seas,
and then you would lower the claw on a three mile long piece of pipe string.
And then like one of those carnival games, you know where you,
you have to grab the toy by remote control.
You would position the claw over the submarine and exactly. So,
and then you would yank it off the bottom of the ocean,
pull it back into the boat.
Gates would open on the bottom of the boat in the claw and the submarine would
come into a chamber and you'd have it. And you're not making any of this up.
I am totally not making it up. The CIA made it up because it just sounds weird,
but they did it. They got the money, they got the approval from the president,
but they still needed a cover story. So they called up Howard Hughes,
the billionaire. Yup. And they ask him or probably his people.
Do you guys think you could just pretend to have this sudden interest in
manganese mining from the bottom of the ocean? That was the cover story. Yes.
Partly because Howard Hughes was a known inventor.
It wasn't in Howard Hughes at this point, living in isolation in Las Vegas,
his fingernails growing inches long and being pretty bizarre.
You know, I don't know if he was living in Las Vegas,
but the rest of that I think is probably pretty accurate. Anyway,
so they ended up building this massive ship. The Hughes Glomar explorer,
the ship was called Glomar. That's where the word comes from. Yeah. It was
by this company called Global Marine Global Marine Glo Mar.
Oh. And in July of 1974
they get the boat out there and they lower the claw.
The Claude descends three miles to the bottom of the ocean where the sub is and
the claw had lights and cameras on it so they could see what was happening.
Do you remember when you first saw it? Yeah, I do.
It was a very badly mangled hole and we could see it very well.
They actually could watch as the clock wrapped its massive claw hand around this
sub and began to pull it back up 14,000 feet,
12,000 feet, about 9,000 feet from the surface.
We were beginning to feel some cautious optimism that we might just pull this
thing off after all. And then I felt a little, just a little,
a little bump in the ship and we went to the control center and everything
looked normal on the television screens.
But then it suddenly occurred to the operators that these, uh,
television images had not been refreshed. In other words,
they were television images taken maybe 15 minutes ago. And, uh,
when they refresh those images and got the real time picture of what was going
on, it showed that we had lost, we'd lost most of the submarine,
basically the part of the sub with nukes, with the missiles,
maybe with the code books and all the stuff they wanted.
That part broke off. And years of work,
millions of dollars just lowly sank to the bottom of the ocean.
Did your heart go Ooh,
yeah,
yeah, yeah. It did. It, uh, it was, it was in
no
intensely, uh,
[inaudible]
emotional. And in the end, did they find anything? We still don't really know.
They've never actually disclosed what they found in that piece.
From David's description, it sounds like they didn't get a lot.
But here's the whole reason I'm telling you this.
It's because not long after that, like intense moment of disappointment,
the story starts to break in the press.
Journalists are starting to call up the CIA.
They're asking all these intense questions, they're onto it.
And the CIA has to figure out what to say and what not to say.
It's the debts. It's a dilemma. There's no question about that.
Which brings us to Walt, Walt Logan, which is just to be clear,
not your actual name. It's a pseudonym. Okay,
so in 1975 Walt was a lawyer at the CIA.
At that time I was the associate general counsel and as the story was breaking
and all these journalists were asking questions,
it became his job to develop the response.
Simple except not so simple. Yes,
there is a diplomatic element of what's going on in here that isn't so obvious
and that is that you have the Soviet Union and the United States at odds
and the problem was that we didn't want the Soviets to know either what we had
found out or what we hadn't found out.
Either way would have been bad since David Sharp.
If we said that we didn't recover any information on Soviet missiles,
which was the truth,
then that would tell the Soviets that they don't have to worry about the
security regarding their warheads. David says, we wanted them to worry.
This is the Cold War. We might as well make them think. We found something.
On the other hand,
if we said that we did recover information on the missiles,
but we're not going to tell you that would be line and they couldn't do that.
We don't.
Governments lie all the time. Why couldn't they lie? Well, because this is 1974
this is the year of Watergate.
This is the year that Congress Raikes,
the entire federal security apparatus over the coals.
This is also the year they revisit something called the freedom of Information
Act.
Well, [inaudible]
brilliant for, yeah. Actually you had been around for awhile,
but that's when Foya finally got some teeth. The law says anybody,
any American should be able to ask the government for documents and the
government has to respond. Right? It has to fork over that information.
You put it this way. Well, it's not a huge fan of this law.
The Glomar was a tremendous investment of time and resources and to Willy Nilly,
give it over to somebody who writes a letter to the agency is,
is preposterous
the way wall sees it.
The CIA's job is to keep secrets and keeping secrets keeps America safe.
Yes. In fact, every CIA employee is legally bound to protect them
being called intelligence sources and methods. It's not an option. It's a law.
Hence his dilemma.
So there he was between a rock and a hard spot under the foil law,
the public has a right to know. On the other hand, under Walt's oath,
he has a legal obligation to not tell.
It's like the classic tension of our times. Exactly. Walt has to say something.
He has to be truthful when he says it,
but he also cannot reveal anything. That's correct.
And people at the agency had been trying to figure this out for months,
which is why they brought in Walt.
And how long did it take you to come up with this kind of response?
I would say probably a half an hour.
Wow.
That half an hour of work has tortured journalists and lawyers for almost four
decades. Here's what he came up with.
The Glomar response was basically the following. We can either
confirm nor deny the existence of the information requested button.
Hypothetically, have such daily work to exist.
The subject matter would be classified and could not be disclosed.
Very straightforward. Now think about that. That's,
that addresses what we were, you were just trying to put your finger on.
You can't confirm it, which would be giving up secrets nor deny it,
which would be a lie, but if it was classified, it couldn't be revealed. Anyway,
suckers.
As you could imagine, people who filed these foyer requests,
when they got a response like that, they were like, that's not going to stand.
You are the sucker. They fought it in court and the fight went on for years.
Knock down, drag out, but eventually the government wins.
The judge ruled in their favor. Well,
the judge agreed to their logic that sometimes revealing even the existence of
documents in dangers, national security, rock man, listen
to,
to make a long story short use of this kind of response exploded to the point
where now you hear actors like will Smith using it.
I can neither confirm nor deny,
nor denied or hear Pixar characters using it. Hollywood publicist.
I can neither confirm nor deny the rumors x Congressman Anthony Wiener,
Congressman Wiener told John Carl that the [inaudible] could neither confirm nor
deny that the photo of was him.
It's become this total boilerplate phrase of our time. I'm gonna,
I'm gonna ask you guys [inaudible] you had personal experience was with Viagara
have, you can't confirm or deny that that was Zac Efron on Conan, but,
but on a much more serious note,
since that initial Glomar response in 1975 more and more government agencies
have begun to use it surprisingly, and not the obvious ones.
We found some from the Department of Commerce, Department of the Treasury,
Department of Energy. It makes you wonder how they got along before then,
centers for disease control.
I was amazed at this thing has legs and it makes you wonder,
why does this thing have legs? Why now? It is weird.
Like that guy, that Propublica guy you, you started with Jeff Larson. Yeah,
that guy. All he's asking is what do you know about who I'd call?
And the only answer he's expecting to get is like, well, you know,
you call your wife, why would they Glomar that?
Well they told them in that letter that if they confirm or deny the existence or
nonexistence of those records,
it would help are the average areas of the United States.
And just just show that I can empathize with the United States of America for a
moment. Why would that be right?
Like if they said you called your wife on Monday at three o'clock,
Thursday at four 30, she called you back at six 15,
what would an enemy then learn? You spoke, I guess that they,
they would learn that, um,
they have records of me calling my wife.
So the statutory reason why I'm,
I've read that your sort of foyas are denied with a Glomar request. Is that,
um, if you say someone is under surveillance by acknowledging records or you say
they're not under surveillance by acknowledging no records, either way,
it outlines the contour of the program.
It's a tiny crack through which people can sort of puncture the wall and get
information about the larger program you go,
you've just given us the government's position. That makes perfect sense to me.
I mean, look, if a thief were to come up and say to me, I'm a cop,
are you investigating me? If I say yes, then he can hide. If I say no,
then he'll go rob another bank, right?
Or the other Roberts will know that I missed a really good bank robber and I'm
terrible at it in any way. I seem like I feel suddenly dangerously exposed.
I don't know. It's all very,
very confusing and you could wrap your brain around it and never get to sleep
for the rest of your life if you thought about it really hard.
And by the way, there is a,
we should say a good argument against that argument from the government that
transparency is a good thing. If you have an agency that uh,
doesn't have any sort of constraints on it or doesn't have the proper oversight,
it oversteps.
And I think that's Dina Temple Rasta in counter terrorism correspondent for NPR.
As Julia was reporting her story,
we ended up calling Dina just to sound her out because she has been glomarred on
drones. She's been glomarred on terrorism investigations. I, I,
I've never actually heard it as being glomarred I have to say.
And she told us something interesting that this whole non denial,
denial state of weirdness has created some very unique situations for her as a
reporter, like say on on any given Monday she sits down,
writes a foyer request about the drone program, which will get glomarred.
Then on Tuesday the government will turn around,
organize a meeting for reporters about the drone program.
Let's say a story about a drone target is out and it seems incorrect to the
White House in a big enough way that they feel they need to correct the record.
So they will often conduct a conference call on background with a number of
reporters from a number of different organizations and basically say to those
reporters, okay,
here are the following people who are talking to you but you are not allowed to
say who they are and they're going to put this in context for you.
And you can quote them as, and they usually set the ground rules, you know,
senior administration official or administration official familiar with the
program or something like that.
And what then happens is they get to correct the record without officially
confirming that something is going on.
I mean there's an interesting thing about the White House and government that
they believe that they still have deniability.
If a high ranking official who is unnamed
says something is going on and as soon as the name is attached to that,
then the information in their view fundamentally changes.
It suddenly becomes concrete.
And actually that's kind of what happened with the project oriented.
That Glomar mission from the 70s even now,
the only reason that we know half of what we know about this whole thing is
because some historians were really dogged with their foyer requests and they
found out about this whole series of internal CIA newsletters.
And in one of those newsletters, there was a,
an article with a title that clued them in that this was about the Glomar
mission. They foyer that specific article. Oh,
and that's what ultimately sprung loose. Yeah.
When they have a name of an article,
then they can foyer that and then it's really hard for them to say no documents
exist because they have the actual title of it. It gets specific. Yes.
So CIA released this article, but I mean by now,
decades have passed and that's what people now say about the Glomar response is
that it's just a delaying tactic because Congress in 2000 I talked to this one
guy, Jameel Jaffer,
he's the deputy legal director of the ACLU and they get glomarred all the,
we've come to expect
them now, unfortunately. He says, you know, I mean, when they get a Glomar,
they don't get upset. They just think, okay,
well we've got another two years in court. That's what it means. It means,
it means you have two years of litigation before you even get to the point of
arguing over whether the government has a right to withhold the information.
W what's happening with this two years? Well, they're trying to strategize.
So if they really want to know about a program and they really want to get those
documents,
they will look for any sort of mention of those documents by public officials in
the same agency.
So say you have a pen and you love this pen,
but you don't want anyone to know about it.
Someone asks you if it exists and you say, hell no. Okay, confirm or deny.
Right? And then you're at a party and you just mentioned it in passing.
You can't help yourself love this pen. She check out this pen, right? Well,
I was nearby. Now I take it to a judge and I say, look,
he's talking about this pen at a party. He's bragging about it.
He can't refuse to confirm or deny its existence anymore.
So they're looking for cracks in the Glomar yeah, over those two years. Yeah.
And it's really expensive legal strategy that most people can't even get to.
Only big outfits like the HCLU can even challenge them.
And the government may ultimately lose in all of these cases,
but it will lose at a time when the public debate will have moved on to
something else. And that's one of the real dangers here.
He says it's that by the time the truth finally comes out
[inaudible]
we don't actually care anymore. It's ancient history
but not for everyone. We'll the divers
who are specially trained going back to that Glomar mission,
the original Glomar mission for a second,
David Sharp says after they were able to pull that last fragment of the sub out
of the water, they were able ultimately to look inside.
And were there people in there?
[inaudible]
there were, there were, uh,
there were three crew members that were basically a
whole and recognizable
and there were major parts of another three crew members,
but they were, they were given the full,
full respect that I think these Soviet Navy would have conferred upon their own
people under those conditions.
The problem was we were keeping the whole thing secret and that allowed the
Soviet government to do the same thing.
They probably didn't want the embarrassment of acknowledging that they'd lost
this really important submarine.
They also didn't want to derail arms talks that we were having with [inaudible].
And for a bunch of other reasons, they just pretended it never happened,
but they had to say something to the families of the sailors who died on that
submarine. Isn't that though?
After you [inaudible] here's the widow of the second in command on the k one 29
name is Irina
[inaudible]. Yep. And a while ago she was interviewed on Russian television.
She's showing the death certificate for her husband, and then she reads it, not
[inaudible]. I'll translate it as best as I can.
So he did [inaudible] death certificate, but he cheated as smear too.
But he's numb on me or show cause of death. Presumed dead. What?
This [inaudible]. CDM.
Horrible. Inhumane death certificate. Yeah. But if she needs, after
[inaudible] cover the Columbian, I don't know who is the author.
I've wanted to know for 30 years who is the author of this horrible,
inhumane document. If I would say to him, the commander Muslim treats it clear,
this is what we've been living with for 30 years. They wrote cause of death,
presumed dead on the death certificate. Yeah. Doesn't even make any sense.
And that that's cruel. Yeah. In this context, it's cruelty.
Uh, that's what she's saying. Giving an answer that says nothing
can be worse than just silence.